David Boder: [In English] Italy, September the 19th, 1946...September the 1st, 1946. In the community Tradate, halfway between Milano and Como. A camp for Jewish displaced...or a castle, which houses a community of Jewish displaced persons, mostly the so called Kibbutzim. Mostly the so-called Kibbutzim, and the interviewee is Mr. Bernard Warsager, an artist, a painter, thirty years of age, who spent some six years in Buchenwald. We will also, instead of taking the whole detailed story, try to get at some high points. This is an experimental approach for the second time of this in this fashion, instead of letting them tell the whole story, just to see whether the high points will bring out sufficient material.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Warsager, wollen Sie mal näher kommen und sprechen Sie hier. Sprechen Sie genügend laut, dass Sie dann dort sehen, dass das Licht dort aufleuchtet, nicht wahr.
Bernard Warsager: Hm.
David Boder: Dann und wann...es braucht nicht immer aufzuleuchten. Und wollen Sie mir sagen, Sie haben mir gesagt also, Sie waren in Buchenwald, nicht wahr?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, ich war...
David Boder: Ja? Wie lange waren Sie in Buchenwald?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war in Buchenwald...am Dreizehnten (13.) Neunten (9.) war ich verhaftet.
David Boder: Was? Was?
Bernard Warsager: Am Dreizehnten (13.) Neunten (9.) war ich verhaftet.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen am Dreizehnten (13.) Neunten (9.)?
Bernard Warsager: Im neunzehn hundert neun und dreißigsten (1939) Jahr war ich verhaftet...
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: . . . war ich verhaftet und...und dann nachher bin ich in ein Gefängnis gekommen, da war ich drei (3) Wochen. Das war hinter Posen, in Branitz.
David Boder: Und dann? Wie lange waren Sie in Buchenwald?
Bernard Warsager: In Buchenwald war ich...
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: . . . von...sechs (6) Jahre.
David Boder: Sechs Jahre?
Bernard Warsager: Seit neun und dreißig (39) bis fünf und vierzig (45).
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie uns nun bitte, warum wurden Sie verhaftet, wo waren Sie, was für ein Staatsuntertane waren Sie und dann—wie ist es Ihnen in Buchenwald persönlich gegangen?
Bernard Warsager: Das hat sich folgend angefangen. Wenn der Krieg ist ausgebrochen zwischen Polen und Deutschland, da war ich eingezogen ins Militär.
David Boder: Ja. Bei wem?
Bernard Warsager: In die polnische Armee.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie gelebt in Polen?
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe gelebt in einer Stadt Tomaszow Mazowiecki.
David Boder: Ja. In welchem Distrikt ist das?
Bernard Warsager: Das ist hundert (100) Kilometer von Warschau.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Bernard Warsager: Also unser Bataillon ist durch die Deutschen unter Warschau gefangen genommen worden. Mir ist es gelungen raus aus...indem ich Zivilkleidung anziehe—nach Hause zu kommen. Der Weg war...der Weg war sehr schwer. Durch die Städte, wo ich bin vorbei, habe ich gesehen Tausende von Juden erschossen, Tausende von Juden verwundet und auch Tausende von Juden zum Erschießen gehen...weil sie sind zum Erschießen geführt geworden.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Nach einer Weile—glücklicherweise ist es mir gelungen nach Hause zu kommen. Das war zwei (2) Tage...
David Boder: Nicht so laut, sprechen Sie hier. Ja, weiter.
Bernard Warsager: . . . zwei (2) Tage vor dem Hoshana.
David Boder: Ja? In welchem Jahr neun und dreißig (39)?
Bernard Warsager: Im neun und dreißigsten (39.) Jahr, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Mee Geschwister und meine Eltern haben sich sehr gefreut, dass ich noch am Leben geblieben und vom diesem Krieg nach Hause gekommen bin.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, wo war Ihr Regiment, wie die Deutschen Sie umzingelt haben und genommen haben?
Bernard Warsager: Es war bei einer Stadt, der Stadt Skierniewicze.
David Boder: Weit von Warschau?
Bernard Warsager: Das war weit. Das war ungefähr so...
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: . . . siebzig (70) Kilometer.
David Boder: Siebzig (70) Kilometer. Ja. Nun, und?
Bernard Warsager: Und ich war zu Hause, nur leider einen Tag. Nachher haben sich die Deutschen eine Methode gefunden. Sie haben alle jungen Leute von siebzehn (17) bis fünf und fünfzig (55) Jahre gesucht—und unter diesem Namen, dass sie sie führen zur Arbeit—haben sie sie geladen in einen großen Lastwagen und eingeladen und weggeführt.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie hier—in diese Richtung, hier. Ja. Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Und das hat auch passiert mit uns. Wir sind mit Autos gekommen nach einer Stadt Czestochowa.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Dort...
David Boder: Haben sie nicht gefragt...haben sie nicht rausgefunden, dass Sie weg gelaufen sind?
Bernard Warsager: Nein.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Vier Tage wurden wir so exportiert...eskortiert mit Soldaten und Waffen von alle Seiten, so dass es war keine Möglichkeit weg zu laufen.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: In Czestochowa haben sie uns sehr geschlagen und nachher haben sie uns umzingelt, rein gesetzt und nach Posen in ein Gefängnis bald geschickt.
David Boder: Aha.
Bernard Warsager: Dort wir waren drei (3) Wochen unter schreckliche Bedingungen. Wir sind geschlagen geworden. Wie wir raus sind aus dem Zug, sind wir so geschlagen geworden, ich hab nie im Leben geträumt, dass ein Mensch kann durch halten solche Schläge.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe nie in meinem Leben gesehen ein Tier so schlagen, wie man hat uns geschlagen. Nach drei (3) Wochen sind wir wieder weg von diesem Gefängnis und sind nach Deutschland gekommen. Wir wussten nicht, warum wir sind hierher gekommen. Man hat uns erzählt, dass wir sollen arbeiten. Und wir sind gekommen in ein Konzentrationslager Buchenwald.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Das Erste was ich hab dort gesehen, hat auf mich einen schrecklichen Eindruck gemacht. Ich habe Menschen gesehen, die blutig sind und man jagt und man schlagt. Man hat Menschen gesehen, die bei Ketten gebunden sind zum Fenster und stehen den ganzen Tag mit Hosen runter gelassen, in schrecklichen Positionen. Schrecklich Zustände. Wir sind zuerst gekommen in eine Stadt Weimar. Die Stadt ist acht (8) Kilometer entfernt von dem Konzentrationslager Buchenwald. Soll ich weiter sprechen?
David Boder: Ja, natürlich.
Bernard Warsager: Wir sind ausgestiegen aus dem, aus der Bahn und wir sind gegangen zu Fuß. Wir mussten die Hände hoch halten und im Laufschritt und die Posten haben uns eskortiert und geschlagen. Und die Leute, die konnten nicht mit laufen, die werden gleich auf dem Weg erschossen.
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Bernard Warsager: Das habe ich selbst gesehen.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Wenn wir sind ins Lager gekommen, hat man uns am zweiten (2.) Tag, hm,...hm, dort eingeschrieben. Jeder musste angeben von welcher Stadt er ist, und seine Abstammung and wie alt er ist. Wir sind gekommen auf einen großem Appell Platz. Auf dem Appell Platz standen vier (4) Zelt Baracken, sehr gross. In eine Baracke konnten tausend Menschen rein. Und diese Baracken waren umgezäunt mit Draht. Dieser Draht war auch...
David Boder: Wo war das in Weimar?
Bernard Warsager: In Buchenwald.
David Boder: In Buchenwald, ja.
Bernard Warsager: Der Draht war auch mit Strom, mit einem elektrischen Strom. Die ersten Tage haben wir noch Essen bekommen; nachher hat es angefangen...es sind hungrige Zeiten geworden. Am Morgen sind wir aufgestanden um drei Uhr früh...und wir mussten stehen bis 11 Uhr abends draußen, nicht angezogen, in der Kälte, wenn es hat geregnet. Es waren immer trübe Herbsttage, und wir waren...
David Boder: In welchem Monat war es?
Bernard Warsager: Es war...es war schon im zehnten (10.) Monat war es schon.
David Boder: Ja. Es war im Oktober?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Und?
Bernard Warsager: Und wir sind gestanden. Am dritten (3.) Tag wenn wir waren dort, mussten wir zur Arbeit raus gehen. Die Arbeit war Folgendes: wir mussten in einen großen Steinbruch runter laufen, sehr tief—und große Steine raus nehmen—raus nehmen aus dem Steinbruch. Die Steine haben gedient zum Straßenbau. Der, der nicht konnte einen großen Stein nehmen, der ist so geprügelt und geschlagen worden von die SS Männer und auch von die deutschen Capos, dass ist gleich das Blut gekommen und er ist bewusstlos auf die Erde gefallen. Ich habe selbst gesehen viele Fälle, dass haben die Menschen den Tod gesucht. Sie konnten schon nicht aushalten die Schläge. Es ist eines...die Capos oder die SS Männer...ohne Schuld von unserer Seite haben sie ausgerufen Häftlinge und haben sie zu tot geprügelt. Ich habe gesehen wie die...
David Boder: Die Capos? Wer waren die Capos?
Bernard Warsager: Die Capos waren Deutsche. Es war auch zwischen die Capos sehr viel politische Deutsche. Politische Deutsche, der hat einen roten...einen roten Winkel getragen. Und es waren auch Capos, hm, hm,...Capos, die haben grüne Winkel getragen. Diese waren...
David Boder: Grüne Winkel waren was?
Bernard Warsager: Kriminal Gefangene.
David Boder: Ja, und?
Bernard Warsager: Die haben sehr sadistisch verbrochen.
David Boder: Wer? Die Politischen auch?
Bernard Warsager: Die Politischen auch. Ein Capo, ein gewisser politischer Capo...
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Der hat einen roten Winkel getragen. Der hieß Herzog.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Der hat Hunderte von Juden auf dem Gewissen. Er hat sie nur mit einem Stock oder mit seiner Faust tot geschlagen. Gesunde Menschen...leider konnten sie sich nicht verteidigen. Aber wenn der Capo ist raus gewesen, er ist frei geworden, dann ist ein anderer Capo gekommen, auch ein Politischer, ein gewisser Vogel. Der hat sich noch sadistischer benommen. Und der Capo davor...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit sadistischem Benehmen?
Bernard Warsager: Sadistisches Benehmen ist Folgendes: Wenn man ein...wenn man einen Menschen nimmt und man heißt ihn sich nieder legen, runter ziehen die Hosen und fünf und zwanzig Stöcke auf den Nackten geben, so dass der Mann kann schon nicht aufstehen und nachher mit der Faust ins Gesicht schlagen, dass er ganz blutig ist. Und wenn das hilft nicht, dann...dann muss der Mann...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie „wenn das nicht hilft“?
Bernard Warsager: Dass der Mann ist nicht tot.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Dann muss er einen sehr großen Stein von dem Steinbruch tragen. Und wenn er trägt rauf den Stein...das ist ungefähr zwei hundert (200) Meter hoch muss er ihn tragen. Und er kann nicht gehen, dann schlagt man ihn in den Kopf rein mit die Stöcke und auf die Hände wo er hält den Stein. Und wenn er raus, hm, hm, den Stein...wenn der Stein raus fällt von die Hände, schlägt man ihn wieder. Und so lange schlägt man bis er unbewusst fällt. Und wenn er ist noch so stark und fällt nicht, dann nehmen sie runter die Mütze vom Kopf und schmeißen sie dort, wo der Posten SS steht und heißen den Mensch laufen, er soll sich die Mütze holen. Wenn der Mensch schon lauft, die Mütze holen, dann wird er erschossen, wie,...wie ein Hund durch die Posten von der SS. Und unter dem Zustand haben wir gearbeitet zwei Wochen. Sehr viel von meine Kameraden habe in dieser Zeit den Tod gefunden. Viele haben auch gesucht den Tod. Sie konnten nicht da zu schauen und das alles durchhalten, was...was man hat uns gepeinigt. Nach aber dieser Zeit waren die Zustände so schlimm in den Zeltlagern, dass eine Ruhr hat ausgebrochen. Eine Krankheit. Und die Deutschen...
David Boder: Eine Ruhr.
Bernard Warsager: Eine Ruhr.
David Boder: Ruhr.
Bernard Warsager: Ruhr...Biegunka.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Die Deutschen haben Angst gehabt, dass sich das kann sich ausbreiten überall und sie haben uns isoliert.
David Boder: Haben Sie es gehabt, sie selbst?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war leider...im Anfang war ich nicht krank, aber in der letzten Zeit bin ich krank geworden.
David Boder: Wann ist es „in der letzten Zeit“?
Bernard Warsager: Das war ungefähr vor Neujahr.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr?
Bernard Warsager: Im neun und dreißigsten (39.) Jahr.
David Boder: Im neun und dreißigsten (39.) Jahr. Ja, nun?
Bernard Warsager: Und Essen haben wir sehr wenig bekommen. Und es war damals in dem Lager ein Fall, dass man hat im Schweinestall ein Schwein gestohlen und deswegen musste das ganze Lager fasten. Und wir haben vier (4) Tage nichts zu essen bekommen. Und wir mussten jeden Tag von drei (3) bis elf (11) Uhr stehen und es hat vielmals geregnet, und was waren so viel trübe Tage und so kalt. Und die Menschen habe es nicht ausgehalten und die Menschen sind gefallen so wie die Fliegen, es war so schrecklich.
David Boder: Haben sie nicht gearbeitet? Wie konnten die sie da stehen lassen den ganzen Tag?
Bernard Warsager: Nein, wir haben nicht gearbeitet, weil diese Krankheit war zu, das war eine zu große Gefahr für die Deutschen. Sie wollen nicht, dass sich die Gefahr soll verbreiten außerhalb vom Lager. Und außerhalb vom Lager sind auch gestanden SS Männer,...das durfte nicht rauskommen. Also es war sehr schlimm. Von unserer Stadt wo verhaftet waren...von diesem Transport waren hundert sieben (107) Juden. Es sind am Leben geblieben sieben (7) Juden. Jeden Tag...jeden Tag sind die Menschen schwächer geworden vom wenig essen. Ich alleine habe gewogen am Ende neun und dreißig (39) auf vierzig (40)...auf vierzig (40) habe ich gewogen neun und dreißig (39) Kilo. Ich habe mich sehr gewundert, denn ich bin gelegen schon in der Ruhr Baracke und hab raus geschaut aus dem Fenster, wie die Menschen bewegen sich. Das waren lauter Skelette. Und man hat gesehen, wenn die Menschen sind gegangen, haben die kleinen Köpfe auf diese Skeletten bewegt links und rechts. Und es war ein Wunder, dass so ein Geschöpf kann herum gehen. Wenn wir sind zum Bad gegangen...
David Boder: Zum wo?
Bernard Warsager: Zum Baden.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Wir sind ein paar Mal zum Baden gegangen. Hab ich nie in meinem Leben so etwas Schreckliches gesehen, ich hab mir nie in meinem Leben vorgestellt, dass Körper von Menschen können so ekelhaft und schrecklich ausschauen, wie wir ausgeschaut haben. Das waren nur Gebeine, nur Gebeine was haben sich bewegt. Und die Zeit ist immer kälter geworden und kälter.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Und immer sind mehr Menschen ge...gestorben. Sind Menschen beim Essen gestorben. Es waren sehr viel Fälle die Menschen haben im Mund den Löffel mit Essen gehalten...und mit dem Essen und mit dem Löffel im Mund sind sie gestorben...und das Essen hat es vom Mund raus gegossen.
David Boder: Wo von sind sie gestorben?
Bernard Warsager: Von Hunger...
David Boder: Nun ja, Hunger war der Grund.
Bernard Warsager: Hunger und Kälte.
David Boder: Hunger und Kälte.
Bernard Warsager: Und von Schläge was man hat öfter bekommen.
David Boder: Aber das Finale...die finale Situation sozusagen, was war es? Herzschlag oder? Was war es? Wie sind sie gestorben?
Bernard Warsager: Die sind...
David Boder: Ich meine, was hat man gesagt? Es waren vielleicht Doktoren dort.
Bernard Warsager: Ja, die SS Männer haben Inspektion gemacht. Wir durften...wir durften nicht eine Ärzte Behandlung haben. Wir sind zum Tod da gewesen, zum Tod!
David Boder: Ja. Hat man,...hat man die Muselmänner genannt? Hat man das Wort Muselmann gehabt in Buchenwald?
Bernard Warsager: Ne, im Anfang war das Wort mir unbekannt. Erst später...noch später, wenn ich bin heraus gekommen von dem Lager, ist mir das bekannt geworden.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Wenn die Sachen mit uns sind bekannt geworden, ich glaube, im Ausland hat man schon gewusst, da sind noch gewesen Beziehungen zwischen Amerika.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Da hat man uns raus gelassen.
David Boder: Von wo?
Bernard Warsager: Von die kleine Zelte sind wir gekommen in das große Lager. Glücklicherweise bin ich ins Revier gekommen, weil ich hab abgefrorene Füß gehabt und man hat mir eine Zehe vom Fuß abgeschnitten Dort—dank dem, dass ich ein Kunstmaler bin von Beruf, ist es mir gelungen dort drei (3) Monate zu sein. Ich habe dort viele Zeichnungen gemacht.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie Malen studiert?
Bernard Warsager: In Warschau in der Kunstakademie.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Wann...wann ich bin raus gekommen, bin ich zugeteilt worden zu einem Kommando von Juden-Steineträger. Und ich habe sehr schwere Zeiten dort mit gemacht. Wir mussten tagtäglich den ganzen Tag runter laufen und rauf mit Steine. Wenn wir sind dort rauf mit die große Steine gekommen und die Steine abgelegt, dann müssen wir im Laufschritt runter laufen in den Steinbruch und haben Schläge bekommen von den deutschen Capos und von den SS Männern. Und das war Tag bei Tag...Tag bei Tag. Die Menschen...unsere [unverständlich] Juden sind gelaufen an der Postenkette. Wir haben keine Hoffnung gehabt, das auszuhalten und haben gesucht den Tod. Es war so: die Posten, die sind herum gestanden, haben zu jedem geschossen, der in die Nähe ist zu diesen gekommen oder wollte durch laufen. Und sehr viele Leute von uns haben sich selbst ermordet oder gezwungen waren sie durch die Capos den Tod zu finden...zu suchen, weil das war zu schwer. Nach ein und ein halb (1 ½ ) Jahr bin ich gekommen in ein neues Kommando. Buchenwald hat angefangen auszubauen. Man hat gemauert Kasernen. Da hab ich angefangen zu arbeiten bei Mauerei als Handlanger, als Gehilfe. Ich hab geholfen. Wir haben Kalk in den dritten (3.) Stock getragen, wir haben Ziegel getragen, wir haben auch Steine getragen und man hat uns geschlagen. Und wenn wir sind, nach dem ganz schweren Tag, jeden Tag in den Block gekommen, da haben wir so zerschlagen, wir konnten sich nicht bewegen und wir mussten noch auf den Appellplatz und beim Appell stehen. Und wenn das alles vorbei war und alle Arier sind in den Block gegangen...mussten wir noch zur Nachtarbeit raus gehen. Und die Nachtarbeit war noch schlimmer. Die deutschen Capos haben uns so geschlagen, dass sehr wenig Leute sind von der Nachtarbeit auch zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Was hat man gearbeitet?
Bernard Warsager: Damals hat sich Buchenwald auch innen entwickelt. Man hat Kantinen gebaut, man hat Keller gegraben. Das Schwerste haben die Juden gemacht. Die mussten als Pferde da Wagen ziehen, und das war auch sehr schwer. Man hat die Juden geschlagen und die Wagen waren so geladen, dass man nicht hat gekonnt ziehen. Den ganzen Tag hat man nur gehört bei den [unverständlich] Kolonnen: „Eins, zwei, drei, vier...eins, zwei, drei, vier...links, zwo, drei, vier“. Den ganzen Tag man hat so die Leute geschlagen. Nachher—das war im zwei und vierzigsten (42.) Jahr hat geöffnet eine Maurer Lehrlingsschule. Und man hat die Juden eingeschrieben in die Schule und man hat sie gelernt Maurer. Haben sich zwei hundert (200)...zwei hundert (200) Juden gemeldet, die wollten Maurer bleiben. Und an einem schönen Tag beim Appell heißt es sämtliche Juden stehen bleiben auf dem Appell. Wenn andere Kommando sind ausgerückt, die Juden müssen stehen. Hat man abgeteilt die Juden, welche Maurer sind und welche Maurer-Lehrlinge, und den Rest hat man isoliert und nach Buchenwald geschickt. Die Juden Fachleute mussten anfangen zu arbeiten als Maurer. Und die haben gemauert die Werke, Rüstungswerke, wo man später auch hat die Wehr ausgearbeitet und auch in der letzten Zeit—im vier und vierzigsten (44.) Jahr—wollten sie V-1 ausarbeiten. Glücklicherweise sind sie von den Bombenangriffen der amerikanischen Truppen in die Luft gesprungen worden alles. Längere Zeit habe ich bei der Mauerei gearbeitet. Und man hat uns sehr viel schikaniert. Wir haben sehr gehungert. Andere...andere Arier haben Zulagen bekommen und von den Juden hat man die Zulagen abgenommen. Es ist auch der Fall gewesen, dass die Juden...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Was heißt Zulagen?
Bernard Warsager: Zulagen heißt, dass...dass jeder Häftling bekommt bei der Arbeit drei Mal im Tag...drei Mal in der Woche bekommt als Zusatz ein Viertel ( ¼ ) Brot zu dem, was er bekommt, zum Beispiel, im Block.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, Herr Warsager, Sie werden das sicher besser kennen als Andere, was für ein Brot hat man dort gegeben? Man sagt, es war ein spezielles Brot.
Bernard Warsager: Das Brot, das wir haben bekommen, das in Buchenwald...
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Das war Militär Brot.
David Boder: Also wie...war das frisch gebacken?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, das Brot war ziemlich gut.
David Boder: Ja, aber wissen Sie, was für ein anderes Brot die gehabt haben? Man sagt, es war Brot, das gebacken war, sechs (6) Wochen...sechs (6) Monate früher und dann gewissermaßen aufbewahrt. Es war ein spezielles gepresstes Brot. Wissen Sie was davon?
Bernard Warsager: Ja. Das Brot haben wir wenig bekommen.
David Boder: Wissen Sie was das ist?
Bernard Warsager: Das habe ich gesehen das Bot.
David Boder: Was war das?
Bernard Warsager: Das war ein gepresstes Brot, das war so leimig das Bot.
David Boder: Man hat es in Sägespäne aufbewahrt?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Wozu?
Bernard Warsager: Das weiß ich nicht wozu.
David Boder: Sie wissen nicht. Nun, also gehen Sie weiter.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben auch öfter bekommen...das Brot war schimmelig.
David Boder: Nun, so, Sie haben keine extra Zulage bekommen. Was war die Zulage? Fleisch? Ich habe...
Bernard Warsager: Die Zulage war ein Viertel ( ¼ ) Brot mit einem Stückerl Wurst.
David Boder: Aha. Aber die Juden haben es nicht bekommen?
Bernard Warsager: Nein.
David Boder: Also?
Bernard Warsager: Und man hat uns sehr gepeinigt bei der Arbeit. Für jede Kleinigkeit haben wir fünf und zwanzig (25) Stock bekommen. Es war da ein Fall, dass...dass Leute...
David Boder: Was waren das? Waren das spezielle Stöcke, die sie denen gegeben haben oder was?
Bernard Warsager: Das waren solche Stöcke von Holz.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Und eine Strafe, eine normale Strafe war, dass die mit die Stöcke haben sie auf den Nackten fünf und zwanzig (25) bekommen—das war eine normale Strafe. Ausserdem die SS Männer haben es erlaubt so zu schlagen, dass man hat gleich den Tod gefunden. Im neun und dreißigsten (39) Jahre haben sie folgendes Experiment gemacht. Die haben genommen zwanzig (20) Juden in den Steinbruch und gleich erschossen— ohne nicht. Sie haben vorgestellt, sie wollen sich lernen schießen. Und sie haben sich ausgelernt—sie haben zwanzig (20) Juden erschossen.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Später, wenn die russischen Kriegsgefangenen sind gekommen, haben sie die Juden ausgesucht und die Juden haben sie gleich erschossen.
David Boder: Was heißt das? Wer hat die Juden? Ah, die Juden von den russischen Kriegsgefangenen!
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Ja! Und sie haben sie gleich erschossen?
Bernard Warsager: Gleich erschossen!
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Es war dort eine...ein Jude hat bekommen einen Zettel ins Revier, da hat er schon gewusst, das ist sein Tod. Da kommt er nicht mehr raus. Und es sind gewesen Fälle, die haben gemacht einmal—aufgeschrieben fünfzehn (15) Leute. Junge Leute, der Älteste war fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahre und haben eine Zettel ins Revier gegeben.
David Boder: Das Revier war das Hospital?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Und was war dort?
Bernard Warsager: Dort...dort haben sie bekommen Spritzen.
David Boder: Und.
Bernard Warsager: Solche Spritzen, die haben in...in ein paar Minuten haben sie nicht mehr gelebt.
David Boder: [In English] This is the end of Spool number 104. We are going over to 106 because on 105 are the songs we have taken this afternoon. An Illinois Institute of Technology Wire recording.
David Boder: Spool number 106. Camp Tara...no, Camp Tradate between Milano and Como. Mr. Warsager, a painter, reporting.
Bernard Warsager: [In German] Also da waren solche Zeiten, wo wir raus gegangen sind zur Arbeit, aber sie haben nicht gewusst, ob sie kommen noch zurück...zurück von der Arbeit. Und so ist vergangen sehr langsam die Zeit.
David Boder: Nun also?
Bernard Warsager: In der Zwischenzeit hat sich Buchenwald immer vergrößert und vergrößert und es ist dann geworden zwei Lager.
David Boder: Was haben Sie für eine Narbe auf dem Gesicht?
Bernard Warsager: Das habe ich bekommen in Buchenwald, noch im neun und dreißigsten (39) Jahr.
David Boder: Was hat man Sie operiert—wo von?
Bernard Warsager: Man hat mich im Revier operiert—zur selben Zeit, wo man mir hat meine Zehe abgeschnitten.
David Boder: Was hat man da operiert am...am Halse?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war ganz geschwollen und man hat mir diese Geschwülste zugeschnitten und...
David Boder: Die Drüsen. Waren das die Drüsen oder war das Kropf? Was war das?
Bernard Warsager: Ich weiß nur, dass es ganz [unverständlich] war, es war von der Kälte.
David Boder: Hat man die ganze...
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Ja und?
David Boder: [In English] He...he has a scar.
David Boder: [In German] Ist es ganz herum um den Hals?
Bernard Warsager: Von hier bis hier.
David Boder: [In English] He has a scar very similar to a goiter operation, but somewhat deeper on the left side. He does not know exactly what the character of the operation was, but it happened at the same time when they amputated one of this toes.
David Boder: [In German] Ja und?
Bernard Warsager: Es war so, dass wir dürfen nicht—auch wenn wir krank sind—in das Revier gehen, weil wenn man ist ein paar Mal gewesen, das war ein Zeichen, dass wir haben mehr keine Berechtigung zu leben. Wenn ein Häftling war zwei (2) Mal, auch drei (3) Mal im Monat, dann hat er einen Schein bekommen und dann musste er im Revier sich melden. Und er ist nicht mehr in den Block gekommen und wir wussten, dass er eine Spritze—eine Impfung zum Tod hat bekommen. Es waren sehr schwere und hungrige Zeiten. Wir haben so gehungert, wir haben nichts zum Essen. Die Arier haben Zulage bekommen und wir dürfen keine Zulage bekommen. Und das zweite Lager bestand...es hat geheißen das „kleine Lager von Buchenwald“. Das ist umzäunt geworden mit Draht. Und dort sind hingekommen sämtliche Zugänge für eine Quarantäne. Und von dort sind sie ins große Lager gekommen.
David Boder: Wissen Sie [unverständlich; spricht ganz leise]. Nun?
Bernard Warsager: In der Zeit wo der Rückzug von die Deutschen hat angefangen, hat sich etwas diese Handlung geändert.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Bernard Warsager: Das war in neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig, da hat es sich schon etwas erleichtert.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Und auch in Buchenwald haben diese innerlichen Amte—haben diese politischen Häftlinge übernommen. Das war eine gewisse Erleichterung, weil bis jetzt haben die „Grünen“, das waren die B V’er, die Kriminellverbrecher, die haben die ganze Macht gehalten bei die Häftlinge.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Aber der Jude war auch zwischen die deutschen Häftlinge immer als minderwertig betrachtet.
David Boder: Zwischen die politischen Häftlinge?
Bernard Warsager: Zwischen die politischen Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Immer als was Minderwertiges betrachtet, nicht als Mensch. Das sind seltene Fälle gewesen, dass man hat betrachtet einen Juden so betrachtet auf diese Gleiche, wie ein Deutscher. Es war auch ein seltener Fall, dass auch der deutsche Kommunist soll nicht erst betrachten als nationaler Deutsche und später als Kommunist. Die Deutschen sind immer...sind immer zuerst gewesen Deutsche und nachher erst „Politische“. Das Bewusstsein, dass er ein Deutscher ist, war bei ihm viel mehr wert, wie dass er ein politischer Häftling ist. Unter auch dieser Maske—politischer—sind verschiedene schmutzige Sachen sind vor gekommen zwischen den politischen Häftlinge. Die Juden hat man bei jeder Gelegenheit schikaniert. Auch die deutschen Häftlinge, die wurden...die wollen sich bei der SS einen guten Namen machen, da haben sie uns bei jeder Gelegenheit schikaniert und auch solche Sachen ausgeführt, dass man hat uns so traktiert schlimmer wie die Hunde. Nur wenn sich die Situation hat geändert in die die letzten Jahre, haben sie etwas anders angefangen uns zu betrachten. Aber wenn es war noch, die deutsche Armee war noch bei Siegen, war es für uns sehr schlimm. Nicht...nicht, dass wir wussten, dass wir nie mehr raus kommen aus dem Lager, nur dass wir konnten sich nicht überhaupt wehren. Zwischen die Häftlinge alleine konnten wir sich nicht wehren.
David Boder: Was heißt das? In welcher Art konnten Sie sich nicht wehren?
Bernard Warsager: Also in dem innerlichen Leben.
David Boder: Haben Sie gehofft, dass Sie werden raus kommen?
Bernard Warsager: Hoffen? Wir haben gehofft, aber logisch betrachtet haben wir gesehen, es gibt keine Möglichkeit da heraus zu kommen auf die Freiheit. Wir waren zum Tod verurteilt. Überhaupt ein Jude hat keine Berechtigung mehr aus dem Lager raus zu kommen. So lange hat er ein Recht zum Leben, wie lange er ist gesund, jung und stark. In dem Fall, wo er krank wird, da ist schon sein Leben zu Ende. Und es war, man hat uns bei der Arbeit immer aufgeschrieben; man wusste nicht für was und für wen. Und wer haben den Zettel für das Revier bekommen und nicht mehr aus dem Revier gekommen zurück. Inzwischen hat das Lager sich vergrößert. Da Lager hat im neun und dreißigsten (39) Jahr hat gehabt sieben tausend (7000) Häftlinge. In neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig ((1944), fünf und vierzig (45) hat das Lager schon gehabt hundert sieben und sechzig tausend (167000) Häftlinge. Ein Teil von die Häftlinge ist auch gewesen im Außenkommando Dora und verschiedene andere Lager. Jeder Häftling, der sich hat dort nicht in Ordnung geführt, ist auf Transport gegangen. Und auch jeder Häftling ist auf Transport gegangen, wenn er hat nicht diesen politischen Häftlingen gefallen.
David Boder: Was heißt „er ist auf Transport gegangen“?
Bernard Warsager: Transport heißt er ist zugeteilt einem anderen Lager. Und das war...das war schon, dass droht mit einem schnelleren und einem schlechten...einem sehr schlechten Tod. Und neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945) wenn die Amerikaner waren schon in der Nähe, da heißt es einen Tag das Arbeitskommando rückt nicht mehr aus zur Arbeit. Und wir haben auch gehofft...vielleicht werden wir, die Juden, am Leben bleiben. Und wir hören durch das Mikrophon, das war, wie wir noch in dem Block waren:“Sämtliche Juden am Appellplatz antreten.“ Und wir haben schon die Schüsse von den amerikanischen Truppe in der Nähe gehört. Und der Kommandant von Buchenwald hat uns versprochen, dass alle Häftlinge...dass er wird das Lager übergeben, so wie es ist, es wird niemandem drohen. Auf einmal...
David Boder: Wer hat er das versprochen? Wer...
Bernard Warsager: Diesen politischen Häftlingen.
David Boder: Er hat den politischen Häftlingen das versprochen?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Haben die mit dem Kommandant reden können?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, die haben verschiedene Posten gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Als Schreiber, als [unverständlich]. Wenn wir haben gehört „Sämtliche Juden am Appellplatz antreten“ und wir haben schon gefühlt, dass die amerikanischen Truppen in der Nähe sind, das ist uns sehr bitter geworden und wir haben gefühlt, dass unsere einzige Chance, dass wir uns vielleicht einmal das Leben retten können, diese Chance ist weg. Wir sind nicht raus auf den Appellplatz. Wir sind raus aus den Blocken und wir sind gelaufen auf dem ganzen...dem ganzen Lager. Ein Teil von uns ist gelaufen zu dem kleinen Lager. Ein Teil von uns hat sich versteckt, wo sie haben können, im Keller, in verschiedenen Lücken. Und diese Nacht, wo wir waren versteckt...das war auch ein Terror Angriff von die Bomben. Und wir haben so gedacht, vielleicht gelingt es das ganze Lager, die SS auch, dass sie nicht mehr existiert in die Luft zu sprengen. Wir wollen unser Leben nicht so billig verkaufen. Am zweiten (2.) Tag ist es, dass das ganze Lager zum Appell antritt. Die Juden mussten auch beitreten. Wenn das ganze Lager da war beim Appell, hört man: „Sämtliche Juden bleiben auf dem Appellplatz. Alle Anderen abtreten.“ Wie wir das gehört haben, sind wir im Laufschritt runter gelaufen und ein Teil hat sich versteckt in die politischen Blöcke, ein Teil hat sich versteckt im kleinen Lager, ein Teil im Revier.
David Boder: Nun haben die Politischen ihnen erlaubt sich zu verstecken?
Bernard Warsager: Also die Politischen haben nicht erlaubt sich zu verstecken. Und die SS ist später runter gegangen und sie haben gefunden viele Juden und die Juden haben sie auch erschossen.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: In dem kleinen Lager haben wir runter gerissen unsere jüdischen Abzeichnung und zugenäht provisorisch andere Nummern, weil es war dort eine große Anzahl von Häftlingen, die sind gewesen ohne Abzeichen und halb tot. Und es war schon eine große [unverständlich] in dem Lager, weil sehr viele Außenkommandos von andere Lager sind rein gekommen, weil sie mussten weg gehen, weil die Truppen, die amerikanischen Truppen waren in der Nähe und sie mussten sämtliche Lager evakuieren.
David Boder: So was haben Sie getan? Weg genommen von andere Häftlinge die Zeichen oder was?
Bernard Warsager: Nein. Jeder Jud hat getragen einen Judenstern, es war ein rotwinkeliges Dreieck und ein gelber.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Aber die Truppen, die Amerikanischen, sind nicht gekommen. Hat man das kleine Lager angefangen zu evakuieren. Ich alleine hatte keine Moeglichkleit länger zu bleiben in dem Lager und ich wollte nicht erkennt werden von der SS als Jude, so bin ich auch raus mit einem Transport.
David Boder: Mit einem Transport...
Bernard Warsager: Von dort...
David Boder: von Christen
Bernard Warsager: Von Buchenwald.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Zusammen mit Juden auch. Es waren auch ein paar Christen dabei. Das war am zehnten (10.) April neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945). Wir sind nach, nach Weimar gekommen und wir sind eingestiegen in die Bahn./
David Boder: Wie weit ist Weimar von Buchenwald?
Bernard Warsager: Acht (8) Kilometer.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben nichts zu essen bekommen, wir waren hungrig auch. Die Strasse von Buchenwald nach Weimar ist gewesen mit Leut und viel Häftlinge, die sind erschossen worden von der SS. Wenn wir sind eingestiegen in den Zug sind wir gefahren. Am zweiten (2.) Tag, dem 11. April, hat eine amerikanische Bombe die Lokomotive durch geschossen und musste raus aus die Züge. Und wir sind gegangen zu Fuß. Hunderte von Kilometern sind wir gegangen zu Fuß.
David Boder: Und die SS ist mit gegangen?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, die SS ist mit gegangen und dann hat sie vielmals gewechselt. Jeder Häftling, der konnte nicht gehen weiter oder der ist auf einen Moment sehen geblieben, ist gleich erschossen geworden. Der Weg war belegt mit Hunderten von Häftlingen, von unsere Juden. Einen schönen Tag, das war der dreizehnte (13) April, da hab ich mir angeschaut mein [unverständlich] und ich hab mir angeschaut die Toten und ich hab gesehen, dass ich hab mehr keinen Ausweg zum Leben. Und ich hat mir vorgenommen, diese Nacht muss ich weglaufen. Wenn sie werden mich erschießen, dann hab ich kein Glück, wenn nicht, dann habe ich vielleicht Glück beim Leben zu bleiben. Und den Abend bin ich ausgerissen.
David Boder: Von wo? Vom Zug?
Bernard Warsager: Nein.
David Boder: Nein.
Bernard Warsager: Von dem Transport.
David Boder: Von der Kolonne?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Wo war die ganze Kolonne gewesen am Abend?
Bernard Warsager: Das war nicht weit von einer Ortschaft, Eisenberg.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Die SS hat geschossen auf mir, aber sie haben mich nicht getroffen und ich bin auf das Feld gefallen. Es war schon finster und ich bin dort gelegen bei einem kleinen Bäumchen. Hab ich gehört nachher wie die...
David Boder: Haben die die Hunde nicht mit gehabt?
Bernard Warsager: Ein Moment.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Nachher habe ich gehört, wie viele Leute, viele von unseren Juden sind gelaufen. Viel Schießerei hab ich gehört und dann ist es ruhig geworden. Nachher habe ich gesehen die elektrische Beleuchtung auf der Chaussee und überall auf den Strassen. Da haben die SS gesucht mit die Hunde diese Häftlinge, die sind weg gelaufen. Und jeder Häftling...
David Boder: Haben die nicht Angst gehabt zu beleuchten wegen der Luftwaffe, wegen ihrer Aeroplane?
Bernard Warsager: Damals, die haben spezielle Beleuchtung gehabt zu beleuchten einen kleinen Fleck.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Für die war es einen große Gefahr, wenn sie haben einen Häftling lebend losgelassen.
David Boder: Aha.
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe auch gehört sehr viel Schießerei. Jeder Häftling, den man hat gefunden, ist gleich erschossen worden. Dort bin ich so gelegen die ganzen Nacht—schwach, ausgehungert. Und früh morgens, wenn es ist licht geworden, habe ich gesehen, man sucht weiter. Ich habe gesehen die Strasse, ich habe gesehen sehr viele...und ungefähr vierzig (40) Meter weit von mir erschießen sie einen Häftling nach dem Anderen, von denen, die sie haben erwischt. So habe ich...so bin ich zwei (2) Tage und zwei (2) Nächte gelegen.
David Boder: Und die Kolonne ist weg gegangen?
Bernard Warsager: Die Kolonne, glaube ich, ist weg. Ich habe nicht...ich war schon so...ich wusste schon nicht mehr was ist los mit mir. Das war am zweiten (2.) Tag—nachdem ich zwei (2) Nächte schon dort gelegen habe. Hab ich mit gedacht, ich kann es schon nicht mehr aushalten, es lohnt sich nicht mehr zu leben und ich werde allein zu der SS gehen, die sollen mich erschießen. Zum Essen habe ich nichts mehr gehabt. Und ich wollte mich nicht mehr peinigen, um von Hungersnot zu sterben. Ich wollte einen schnellen Tod haben. Und ich bin aufgestanden. Und ich bin aufgestanden und ich bin ein paar Schritte gegangen und bewusstlos nieder gefallen und eingeschlafen. Ich war viel zu schwach von dem Hunger. Und wenn ich bin so gelegen, hab ich geschaut...ich habe gesehen sehr viel Militär von die Wälder kommen und von überall rausgehen, die sind ohne Gewehr raus gegangen. Ich habe mich gewundert: ‚Was ist das?’ Und plötzlich sehe ich ein paar Menschen gehen. Ich habe erkennt, das waren auch Juden, Häftlinge. Und sie sind zu mir gekommen, da hab ich Kraft bekommen. Sie sagen zu mir: „Guck in den Wald, die Deutschen laufen weg.“ Und wir sind in den Wald gegangen, da hab ich gesehen sehr viele Waffen, alle laufen, alles weg geschmissen—Waffen, alles. Und ich hab gefunden ein paar Stück Zucker dort...die ein deutscher SS Mann hat zurück gelassen mit seinem ganzen Rucksack. So habe ich es genommen. Und mit einem Mal sehe ich nun viele deutsche Soldaten der Wehrmacht und SS stehen und sie sehen wie die Glocken klingen. Wir haben verstanden, da muss etwas passiert sein. Wir sind zu gegangen, da haben die Deutschen ausgestreckt zu uns die Hände und haben gesagt: „Nun, wir sind Eure Kameraden, die Amerikaner sind schon da. Ihr habt gelitten, wir auch. Wir sind die Kameraden. Wir haben...“
David Boder: Die SS haben das gesagt?
Bernard Warsager: Die SS auch, die Wehrmacht und die Anderen. Wir haben nichts gesagt und sind los gegangen und dort sind schon gewesen amerikanische Truppen. Die Ortschaft hat geheißen Eisenberg.
David Boder: Was?
Bernard Warsager: Eisenberg.
David Boder: Eisenhower?
Bernard Warsager: Eisenberg hat die Ortschaft geheißen, wo ich...
David Boder: Eisen...Eisenberg, die Ortschaft hat geheißen Eisenberg?
Bernard Warsager: Eisenberg.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Dort war ich drei (3) Tage.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie da?
Bernard Warsager: In dem...ich war dort bei einem Gutsbesitzer.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Drei (3) Tage.
David Boder: Nun, hat er sie aufgenommen? Hat er gewusst Sie sind ein Jude?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, er hat schon gesehen, was ist los.
David Boder: Ja. Nun was hat er gesagt?
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe ihm zuerst nicht gesagt, dass ich bin Jude. Später beim Wegfahren...
David Boder: Nun, was hat er gesprochen in diesen drei (3) Tagen? Was hat er über die politische Lage gesagt?
Bernard Warsager: Er hat nichts zu tun gehabt mit die...mit die SS Männer. Später haben wir gewusst, er hat auch zu der SS Partei gehört. Und das war sehr ein reicher Mann.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Aber wir waren so abgeschwächt, dass die ganze Welt hat uns nicht interessiert. Wir konnten sich nicht bewegen.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Von dort sind wir gekommen nach Erfurt. Erfurt...
David Boder: Erlauben Sie mir Ihnen eine psychologische Frage zu stellen.
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Ich kann nicht auf einen andere Weise diese Frage so stellen. Sie sagen Sie sind zwei (2) Tage und zwei (2) Nächte so gelegen ohne zu essen.
David Boder: Wie fühlt man das? Was haben Sie gedacht? Was...was...haben Sie geschlafen? Was haben Sie im Allgemeinen? Was ist mit Ihnen vorgegangen?
Bernard Warsager: Also ich habe...ich unterstreiche es. Wenn wir sind raus aus Buchenwald haben wir ja auch nichts zu essen bekommen. Und wir waren sehr ausgehungert. Es war am ersten Tag eine Angst vor dem Tode. Der Mensch will sich...will auf jeden Fall am Leben bleiben. Und das Gefühl von Hunger im ersten Moment ist das stark, nachher kann man sich nicht helfen. Ich hab genommen Blätter von dem Baum und Gras in den Mund genommen und ich...es war so bitter, ich kann das nicht vertragen. Und es war mir sehr schlecht, ich konnte nichts...so bin ich da gelegen. Ich bin gelegen und hab geschlafen und hab geguckt was auf der Strasse vor sich gegangen ist, was die SS macht und hab alles gesehen. Aber mit der Zeit ist mir der Hunger vergangen, ich hab schon nicht mehr einen Hunger gefühlt. Aber ich habe gelitten, ich war schwächer—ich habe gesehen, dass...dass...dieses schrecklich Gefühl. Ich wollte nicht so sterben. Ich komme von...
David Boder: Wo war dieses Gefühl? Im Magen, in der Brust?
Bernard Warsager: Im Magen.
David Boder: Im Kopf?
Bernard Warsager: In der Brust...ich habe gefühlt so immer schwächer, schwächer...und im Mund habe ich auch so ein schlechtes Gefühl.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Bernard Warsager: Nachher hat man uns nach Erfurt geführt, da war schon ein Lager. Dort ist es schon besser gewesen. Es war dort die Belegung von UNRRA, vom Roten Kreuz und dort war ich eine Zeit. Die amerikanischen Truppen haben befreit Buchenwald und auch Thüringen, das ganze Thüringen und Weimar. Und auf einmal heißt es, dass die amerikanischen Truppen zurück ziehen sich und die russische Armee übernimmt die ganze Zone.
David Boder: Ein Moment. Ich möchte Sie eine andere Anekdote fragen. Es sind da ein paar Sachen, die Sie mir vor diesem Interview gesagt haben. Erstens Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben in Buchenwald Psychologie studiert.
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Wie ist das gekommen?
Bernard Warsager: Also die Sache ist Folgende. Ich habe sehr gute Freunde gehabt.
David Boder: Unter den Politischen—Christen?
Bernard Warsager: Juden.
David Boder: Juden. Und.
Bernard Warsager: Juden. Auch Menschen von den verschiedenen Ecken von der Welt. Und die haben auch in der freien Zeit viel von dieser Kenntnis von sich über gegeben. Und Buchenwald hat gehabt eine Bibliothek in verschiedenen Sprachen, eine Bibliothek mit fünf und dreißig tausend (35000) Werken.
David Boder: Haben Sie eine Idee wie diese Bibliothek dorthin gekommen ist?
Bernard Warsager: Jeder Häftling war berechtigt von dieser Bibliothek Bücher zu bekommen.
David Boder: Aber ich meine, von wo hat Buchenwald die Bibliothek bekommen? Wie ist es hin gekommen dort?
Bernard Warsager: Viele Häftlinge haben geopfert Bücher.
David Boder: Aha.
Bernard Warsager: Gespendet Bücher.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Es hat gegeben Bücher in verschiedene Sprachen und sehr gute Bücher. Und dank der Bücher hatte ich die Möglichkeit meine Wissenschaft zu vergrößern.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie gelesen und wo?
Bernard Warsager: In der freien Zeit habe ich gelesen—jeden Abend.
David Boder: War da Licht genug in den Baracken?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, eine Stunde oder eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde habe ich immer gehabt Zeit, drei (3) Mal in der Woche zu lesen.
David Boder: Aha. Warum drei Mal in der Woche?
Bernard Warsager: Oh, nicht jeden Tag hat man da Zeit.
David Boder: Aha. Und?
Bernard Warsager: Weil wir sind...selten ist alles so gewesen, dass der Appell normal vergangen ist. Wir mussten zwei (2), drei (3), auch vier (4) Stunden auf dem Appellplatz stehen. Ob es regnet, ob es kalt ist und weil das hat nicht immer gestimmt.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Die Rechnung hat nicht immer gestimmt und wenn ein Häftling hat gefehlt oder wenn die Deutschen waren schlecht aufgelegt, dann mussten wir auch ganze Nächte stehen auch. Ja,...
David Boder: Also, Sie sind dann hingekommen nach wohin? Man hat gesagt, dass die Russen nehmen das über? War das wahr?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl, nachher sind die Russen gekommen.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie dann?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war in Erfurt.
David Boder: Haben die Russen Buchenwald uebernommen?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl, später.
David Boder: Und dann habe sie es wieder zurück gegeben? Jetzt ist Buchenwald unter...Buchenwald ist unter...
Bernard Warsager: Ist unter dem russischen Regime.
David Boder: Jetzt? Buchenwald?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl. Aber ich möchte zurück gehen und das mehr beschreiben.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Ich hab sehr viel Kameraden gehabt...
David Boder: [sehr leise] Sprechen Sie hier hin.
Bernard Warsager: . . . und wir alle waren...wir alle waren Zionisten. Wir dürfen das nicht zeigen. Wer Zionist war in Buchenwald, der ist gleich auf Transport gegangen.
David Boder: Bei die Deutschen.
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl. Und wir mussten auch die Arbeit führen illegal.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe heute Freude, dass viele von meine Kameraden, wo wir waren zusammen jetzt sechs Jahre, jetzt in Eretz sind.
Bernard Warsager: Und wir haben auch auf den Appells, die lange waren—oft vier (4) und fünf (5) Stunden in der Kälte, da haben wir auch gesprochen. Wenn wir mal da das große Glück haben und Freiheit zu bekommen und der Krieg ist beendet, dann haben wir Großes geleistet. Und die Juden, die sind am Leben geblieben werden große Leistungen haben und...und ich...
David Boder: Große was?
Bernard Warsager: Leistungen im Leben. Und Eretz wird sicher auf sein für sämtliche Juden, die wollen nach Eretz kommen.
David Boder: Ich habe nicht verstanden. Was meine Sie mit Leistung?
Bernard Warsager: Dass wenn wir mal in die Freiheit kommen und der Krieg wird zu Ende sein...
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: . . . wird jeder Jude, der wollte nach Palästina fahren wird keine Beschwerde habe.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Dass England wird alles Mögliche machen...
David Boder: Nicht so laut [flüstert]
Bernard Warsager: . . . dass sie den Juden freie Einreise nach Palästina geben.
David Boder: Ein Moment. [flüstert] Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Also wir sind befreit geworden, aber diese Freiheit, die hat uns so viel gekostet, die hat uns sehr enttäuscht.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, Sie haben doch Familie in Polen gehabt. Sind Sie nicht zurück gegangen, um zu seh, was dort passiert ist?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, ich war in Polen, zwei ein halb (2 ½ ) Wochen war ich da.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war auch auf dieser Strasse, wo ich hab gewohnt. Ich war auch bei dieser Wohnung, wo ich bin aufgezogen geworden. Ich war auf dem Hof. Ich durfte nicht von den Früchten...die Früchte runter nehmen, obwohl es war unser Eigentum.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Bernard Warsager: Warum? Erstens weil ich Jude bin. Ein Jude, der noch etwas hat in Polen, da ist es besser wenn er...wegkommt, weil wenn er bleibt, da droht ihm der Tod. Und mir war das zu peinlich, weil ich habe gesehen fremde Leute, die mein Eigentum haben, die in meiner Wohnung wohnen. Aber das Schrecklichste war, dass ich hab Niemanden mehr gefunden. Von einer Familie was hat gerechnet sieben (7) Leute, bin ich alleine geblieben.
David Boder: Wer war in Ihrer Familie?
Bernard Warsager: Das war mein Vater, meine Mutter und sechs Geschwister.
David Boder: Hat man niemand...haben Sie keinen gefunden?
Bernard Warsager: Nein. Die waren im zwei und vierzigsten (42) Jahr, wie man hat mir erzählt, bei der ersten Aussiedlung . Sie sind nach Treblinka gekommen und dort hat man sie ermordet in die Gaskammern.
David Boder: Waren das nicht jüngere Menschen, die zur Arbeit selektiert werden konnten?
Bernard Warsager: Die wollten dass,...von dem was ich hab gehört, sie wollten vernichten sämtliche Juden. Nun sie haben zurück gelassen nur die Fachleute, welche sind ihnen zu Nutzen gekommen. Mein Brüder und mein Vater hat, hat die...Handelsschule, das durfte nicht mehr sein und meine Brüder haben...
David Boder: Was hat Ihr Vater getan?
Bernard Warsager: War Buchhalter.
David Boder: : War Buchhalter. Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, und nachher war er der Direktor von einer Tuchfabrik.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Und meine Brüder, die waren auch in der Schule, der eine war Student, die leben nicht...niemand lebt mehr.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Das hat mich so erschüttert, dass ich wollte nicht mehr bleiben.
Bernard Warsager: Und die Beziehung von die Polen zu die Juden war auch nicht sehr freundlich. Jeder Jude, welcher ist auf der Strasse war,...so hat man gesagt „Oh“, in der polnischen Sprache „Patrz sie, znowo kot“. Das ist wieder eine Katze, sie ist wieder da.
David Boder: Oh, das haben die Polen gesagt?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Sie haben sich gar nicht gefreut, dass die Juden wieder da sind?
Bernard Warsager: Im Gegenteil. Wenn der Jud noch etwas hat abzunehmen...es hat gegeben sehr viele Fälle—man hat ihn getötet.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Ich bin zurück gekommen nach Deutschland, ich bin gekommen nach Schwandorf. Von dort nach Deggendorf in ein jüdisches Camp, die haben einen Kibbuz gegründet—Habderaki.
David Boder: Wie gründet man einen Kibbuz? Muss man Erlaubnis haben von irgendwelcher Organisation?
Bernard Warsager: Das war...als Juden dürfen wir eine Gruppe...das ist eine zionistische Bewegung.
David Boder: Muss man Erlaubnis von dem Zionisten Kommittee haben, um einen Kibbuz zu gründen?
Bernard Warsager: Selbstverständlich.
David Boder: Also erklären Sie das ein bisschen.
Bernard Warsager: Also es findet sich eine Gruppe von Menschen, welche wollen zusammen nach Palästina fahren und zusammen leben.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Und man nimmt sich zusammen, man wohnt auch zusammen, man lernt hebräisch zusammen. Man macht [unverständlich; hebräisches Wort—klingt wie: toshino sigar], man macht kulturelles Leben, jüdische Geschichte und alles geht in dem Sinn von zionistische Strebungen aus, auch kulturell, wir haben eine eigene Zeitung. Einer lernt dem Anderen die Wissenschaft und wir haben uns vorbereitet auf unser zukünftiges Leben in Eretz.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Leider haben die Engländer ganz anders behandelt diese Frage...und nicht so wie Freunde, sondern wie die schrecklichsten Feinde haben sie uns betrachtet. Sie wollten uns nicht mehr rein lassen nach Palästina.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben keinen anderen Ausweg und wir haben keinen anderen Weg. Das ist unser eigenes Ziel und wir sind berechtigt dieses Ziel zu erreichen. Für uns gibt es keine Grenze, keine Gesetze. Vor allem keine Gesetze von Menschen, die kein Verständnis haben, die nur wollen imperialistische Politik geben und wir haben gesagt: „Und stört nichts, uns schrecken keine Grenze, keine Gesetze, wir werden das Ziel erreichen. Ich will...ich wollte nach Palästina fahren. Ich bin raus gefahren mit einer Gruppe von sechs und vierzig (46) Menschen.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Leider sind wir angehalten geworden bei die...bei der holländischen Grenze.
David Boder: Von wo sind Sie gefahren nach wo?
Bernard Warsager: Ich bin gefahren von...
David Boder: Mit den sechs und vierzig (46) Menschen?
Bernard Warsager: Bin ich gefahren von Deggendorf.
David Boder: Deutschland?
Bernard Warsager: Deutschland.
David Boder: Wohin?
Bernard Warsager: Ich wollte nach Holland kommen.
David Boder: Und dann?
Bernard Warsager: Dann wollte ich mich...dann wollte ich fahren nach Palästina.
David Boder: Von Holland direkt?
Bernard Warsager: Wir müssen [unverständlich; Rauschen im Tonband] so einen Weg, dass wir hin kommen. Es ist das nicht wichtig, was für ein Weg.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Für uns gibt es keine Gesetze, weil die Gesetze sind unrecht für uns.
David Boder: Warum? Nein, ich meine nicht die Gesetze. Ich meine, wie hat man Möglichkeit in Holland ein Schiff zu bekommen nach Palästina zu gehen?
Bernard Warsager: Wenn man kriegt in Holland keine Schiffe, dann gehen wir in ein anderes Land, wo wir Schiffe bekommen. Wir müssen durch gehen.
David Boder: War es nicht logisch gleich vom Beginn zu gehen entweder nach Italien oder nach Griechenland?
Bernard Warsager: Ne, wir hatten damals bessere Möglichkeiten von dort.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, also?
Bernard Warsager: Leider sind wir gehalten worden...angehalten worden von englischen Patrollen an dieser...
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: . . . auf dieser Grenze.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Und wir sind ins Gefängnis gekommen. Von dort sind wir gekommen in ein...
David Boder: Warum war die englische Patrolle an der holländischen Grenze? Ah, an dieser Seite. Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl. Wir waren noch auf dieser englischen Seite.
David Boder: In...
Bernard Warsager: In Deutschland.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Es war so, dort waren wir ein paar Tage—nachher sind wir gekommen nach...
David Boder: Wo waren Sie ein paar Tage? Im Gefängnis?
Bernard Warsager: Im Gefängnis. Nachher sind wir gekommen, das war am vierten (4.) Januar wie wir sind verhaftet geworden.
David Boder: Sechs und vierzig (46)?
Bernard Warsager: Im sechs und vierzigsten (46.) Jahr.
David Boder: Ja, in diesem Jahr.
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl, in diesem Jahr. Sind wir von diesem dort in ein Lager gekommen. Das heißt Internierungslager.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: In Wirklichkeit ist das ein Konzentrationslager. In ein Lager, wo die größten Kriegsverbrecher, SS, Nazi Verbrecher waren, dort hat man uns rein gesteckt. Und wir Juden, die wir haben gelitten so viel von der SS, das haben sechs Millionen (6000000) umgebracht, haben sie es erlaubt die deutsche Seite [unverständlich]. Sechs und vierzig (46) Juden, die wollten nur nach Palästina fahren, zusammen mit den größten Kriegsverbrechern. Das ist das größte Verbrechen, was man kann...was man kann sich erlauben gegen Juden.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie, was für Leute sind zusammen gewesen dort?
Bernard Warsager: Ich war dort zusammen mit Krupp, von Bülow, mit Hitler’s Sekretär war ich zusammen. Ich war zusammen mit dem...mit einem guten Freund...
David Boder: Von Bülow war Hitler’s Sekretär?
Bernard Warsager: Nein, ich weiß nicht, ob er es war, aber ich war...
David Boder: Wer war Hitler’s Sekretär?
Bernard Warsager: Ich denke nicht mehr an den Namen.
David Boder: Nun ja, ich wollte nur den Namen vermerken. Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Und dann die verschiedenen Gauleiter, Generäle.
David Boder: Nun, das war ja eine Ehre, die Sie hatten, die Engländer haben Sie sehr gut gehalten. [lacht]
Bernard Warsager: Ja. Die Engländer wollten von uns raus bekommen sehr viele Sachen über uns. Wer führt uns. Wer schickt uns nach Palästina. Die haben uns zu essen nichts gegeben. Die haben ein Brot auf acht (8) Teile gegeben, das war unser Essen den ganzen Tag. Die Deutschen durften Pakete empfangen. Wir dürfen keine Pakete haben. Die Deutschen haben Post geschickt. Wir dürfen keine Briefe erhalten oder schicken Post zu jemand. Und so hat man uns gepeinigt drei Monate. Moralisch, sie haben uns verhört fünf und zwanzig (25) Stunden. Sie haben uns in den Bunker. Verhört haben sie uns in einer speziellen Ortschaft [unverständlich]. Ich kann mich in dem Moment nicht erinnern, wie diese Ortschaft. Verschiedene Offiziere haben uns verhört. Sie haben uns ganz nackt bei der Revision ausgezogen. Wir haben es noch schlimmer gehabt, wie in dem Konzentrationslager. Nun das Gefühl, dass wir Juden haben das Glück gehabt befreit zu werden, nur zu sitzen zusammen unter einem Dach mit die größten Kriegsverbrecher, war das Schrecklichste. Zwischen uns war ein Mädel, das war verheiratet und sie war schon acht (8) Monate schwanger. Und sie wollten sie nicht ins Spital schicken und auch nicht befreien. Was in dem Fall, wenn eine deutsche Frau nur im dritten (3.) oder vierten (4.) Monat ist, da hat man sie gleich befreit. Aber uns nicht. Durch einen Zufall hat sich ein jüdischer Kapitän gewusst, dass da Juden eingesperrt sind und das war unser Glück.
David Boder: Was hat er getan?
Bernard Warsager: Der hat sich die größte Mühe gegeben, man soll uns befreien.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie mit den deutschen Häftlingen geredet? Haben Sie mit Krupp geredet?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl, ich habe mit Krupp geredet. Wir haben auch zwei Mal am Tag zu Appell gestanden.
David Boder: Ist er auch zu Appell gestanden?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Was für Kleider hat er getragen?
Bernard Warsager: Zivilkleider haben sie alle getragen.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie gesehen innen wie er lebt? Hat er seine Sachen mit gehabt?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl. Der hat Pakete bekommen. Alle Deutschen haben Pakete bekommen. Wir durften keine erhalten.
David Boder: Nun.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben auch mit die Engländer gesprochen. Wir haben ihnen gesagt, wir haben so viele Jahre im KZ gelitten. Sechs (6) Jahre. Wir haben sämtliche Verwandte verloren und dieselben Mörderer sind zusammen mit uns. Was für ein Verbrechen haben wir...? Die englischen Offiziere haben uns alles versprochen. So wie immer—sie versprechen alles, aber kein Wort haben sie nicht gehalten. Bei dem Verhör auch, die sind so kaltblütig. Ich habe noch nie im meinem Leben gesehen solche kaltblütige Menschen sich benehmen, wie die haben sich benommen. Mit einer...
David Boder: Aber sie haben Sie doch nicht geschlagen während dem Verhör...die Engländer?
Bernard Warsager: Es waren Fälle—die haben uns geschlagen auch. Die haben uns vier (4) Tage ganz nackt ausgezogen.
David Boder: Das heißt jedes Mal?
Bernard Warsager: Im Bunker.
David Boder: Was ist ein Bunker?
Bernard Warsager: Bunker das ist ein unterirdisches Loch. Es ist für den Angriff, den Fliegerangriff gebaut. Da haben sie uns rein gesteckt.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 106, the report of Mr. Warsager. We are going over to Spool 107 with the continuation of his story.
David Boder: September 1, 1946, Tradate, a little camp for displaced people, especially Kibbutzim, especially, hm, Jewish Groups, which are preparing to go to Palestine; between Milano and Como.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Warsager...
David Boder: [In English] This is a continuation of Spool 106, this is Spool 107. Mr. Warsager reporting.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Warsager, was sagen Sie, die Englischen haben Sie abgefragt in die Bunker? Wozu ist man gegangen in die Bunker?
Bernard Warsager: Die wollten...sie sagen, sie wollten die ganze Wahrheit von Euch wissen. Dann wird Euch nichts passieren. Wer schickt Euch nach Palästina und wer ist [unverständlich]?
David Boder: Ja, aber warum die Bunker? Warum haben die keine Zimmer gehabt? Was heißt Bunkers?
Bernard Warsager: Warum?
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Bunkers habe ich Ihnen schon erklärt.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Das sind spezielle Räume unter der Erde, welche sind gegen Fliegerangriff, gegen Bomben.
David Boder: Nun ja, aber es war doch kein Krieg mehr.
Bernard Warsager: Aber wir sollten doch bestraft werden. Wir sollen bestraft werden, dass wir doch die Wahrheit sagen.
David Boder: So sind Sie gesessen im Dunklen?
Bernard Warsager: Ganz im Dunklen. Wir haben Brot und Wasser bekommen.
David Boder: Bei den Engländern?
Bernard Warsager: Bei den Engländern, bei den ganz kultivierten Engländern.
David Boder: Könnten Sie schwören dazu?
Bernard Warsager: Ich kann schwören, ich kann es unterschreiben und schwören dazu.
David Boder: Nun, gehen Sie weiter.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben verloren zwanzig (20) Kilo, zwischen fünfzehn (15) und zwanzig (20) Kilo, jeder.
David Boder: Wieviel Menschen waren Sie da?
Bernard Warsager: Sechs und vierzig (46) Menschen.
David Boder: Frauen und Männer.
Bernard Warsager: Ja und inzwischen auch eine schwangere Frau, die war im achten (8.) Monat. Sie dürfte nicht frei gelassen sein, weil sie eine Jüdin ist. Und die SS Männer...die Frauen von die SS Männer, die große Verbrecher sind, die auch viele Juden auf dem Gewissen auch haben, die hat man befreit, wenn sie in anderen Umständen waren.
David Boder: Hat man die Frauen und Männer von Ihrer Gruppe zusammen gehalten?
Bernard Warsager: Nein, extra. Wenn ein Mann wollte sich sehen mit seiner Frau, dann konnte er sie nicht sehen. Und wenn es war ein Fall, dass man [unverständlich] dann hat man gleich gewollt ihn erschießen.
David Boder: Nun, weiter.
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe mir nie vorgestellt, dass die Engländer werden sich so gemein zu uns benehmen. Und das war diese traurige Enttäuschung, was wir haben erlebt. Ich habe mir nie vorgestellt, dass die Engländer,...das sind doch kulturelle Menschen. Sie würden sich nie auf solche sadistische Barbareien...so wie die Deutschen.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe mir nie vorgestellt, dass die...dass die würden uns so behandeln so wie die Deutschen, noch schlimmer, wie die größten Verbrecher, die Nazi.
David Boder: Nun.
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben...
David Boder: Was soll das heißen „noch schlimmer“? Reden Sie doch nicht...man muss doch vorsichtig sein. Haben die Engländer Sie geschlagen?
Bernard Warsager: Also ich sage Ihnen, ich bin verantwortlich für meine Worte.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Ich sage jedem Engländer, vor Gericht kann ich schwören.
David Boder: Nun ja. Also wollen Sie mir sagen, haben die Engländer sie geschlagen?
Bernard Warsager: Ich werde es Ihnen sagen. Die Engländer haben alle, viele Methoden, die sind schlimmer, wie schlagen.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Bernard Warsager: Zum Beispiel: sie haben uns hungern gelassen.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Aber das ist noch nicht das Schlimmste. Wir sind gewohnt zu hungern. Das Schlimmste ist das, wie kann man einen Juden, der kein Verbrecher ist, zusammen setzen mit solchen Kriegsverbrechern? Ich kann das nicht in meinem Hirn begreifen, kann ich nicht, wie man kann Juden zusammen mit solchen Gauleitern, welcher mit einer Unterschrift haben sie Tausende von Juden ins Krematorium geschickt. Wie kann man solche Juden, die haben das Glück am Leben zu bleiben, zusammen setzen mit diese Verbrecher?
David Boder: Haben Sie gesagt, Sie wollen nicht zusammen sein mit diesen...?
Bernard Warsager: Wir haben gesagt, wir haben gebeten, alle Mögliche haben wir getan.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Sie haben gesagt „Leider haben wir keine anderen Lager“. Und das ist die größte Lüge, da gibt es genug, wo man hat uns gekonnt isolieren. Aber sie wollten uns zerbrechen. Und die werden uns nie zerbrechen. Die kennen aber diese Methoden, was die Nazi Verbrecher haben gemacht, dass sie sechs (6) Millionen Juden haben ermordet. Die Engländer können das auch machen. Gegen Gewalt können wir nix machen, aber geistig werden sie uns nie zerbrechen. Physisch können sie mit Gewalt uns viel machen. Und das ist eine große Schande, dass sie haben sich so was erlaubt.
David Boder: Nun, wollen wir zu einer anderen Frage übergehen. Sie sagen, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben mit Krupp und den Anderen gesprochen.
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Haben Sie sie gefragt, wieso Deutschland so niedrig gefallen ist mit Leuten, mit Juden so umzugehen.
Bernard Warsager: Ja, wir haben ihm das gesagt. Ich werde gleich sagen, das war ein gelernter Mann und er hat gesagt, dass er hat von diese Taten gar nichts gewusst. Er hat nur gemusst ausführen Befehle. Und er war dagegen, er war ein großer Freund von Juden. So hat er das gesagt.
David Boder: Nun und die Anderen?
Bernard Warsager: Es ist interessant. Alle Nazi sagen dasselbe, dass sie waren sehr große Freunde von die Juden. Die Engländer sagen auch, sie sind große Freunde. Der Offizier, der mich hat verhört fünf und zwanzig (25) Stunden, der sagte auch, er ist ein großer Freund von Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Und viele Andere auch, aber die Behandlung war sehr weit von Freundschaft.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Und das wird uns auch für das ganze Leben,...für mich persönlich wird das bleiben. Die drei (3) Monate sind vielleicht stärker eingebaut in mir...
David Boder: Warum haben die Sie so lange gehalten? Drei Monate?
Bernard Warsager: Ich glaube, sie wollten uns so lange halten, wie möglich lang. Aber durch einen Zufall war ein englischer Captain, der auch auf dem Gebiet war, wie alle jüdischen Soldaten in der englischen Armee. Der hat über uns gehört und er hat sich bemüht uns zu befreien.
David Boder: Nun war es sein spezielles Geschäft sich mit der jüdischen Frage zu beschäftigen?
Bernard Warsager: Sein Geschäft war mit die jüdischen Soldaten.
David Boder: Englische jüdische Soldaten?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, war er ein Geistlicher? War er?
Bernard Warsager: Interessant ist das, dass jeder Deutsche, der von Lager befreit ist, da bekommt er ein spezielles Buch, dass er befreit ist von dem Lager. Und wir sind befreit geworden, dass man hat uns raus geführt, so dass niemand darf wissen, dass wir haben einmal in dem Lager gewesen. Das war eine zu große Schande für...für die meisten Offiziere, was sie sich haben da erlaubt.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Wenn wir sind raus gefahren von dort waren wir wie immer voll von Geist. Wir haben auch gesungen und englische Soldaten, auch Offiziere, welche sind vorbei gegangen, die haben geschimpft: „Jew, fuck you, Jew.“
David Boder: Die haben auf Euch geschimpft?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, sie waren alle...alle sind sehr freundlich gestimmt gewesen. Und wir haben gesagt: „Wir werden weiter unseren Weg suchen. Und wenn wir wieder fallen in eure Hände, da wissen wir schon mit wem wir haben zu tun, aber wir schrecken sich nicht. Und diese Frau—wir haben gebeten, man soll diese Frau befreien, die war im achten (8) Monat. Es hat gar nicht geholfen. Zur selben Zeit hat man viel deutsche Frauen befreit, die waren im vierten (4.) und fünften (5.) Monat. Und die Frau wollte man nicht befreien.
David Boder: So wie ist sie herausgekommen und wann?
Bernard Warsager: Sie...sie ist zusammen mit uns rausgekommen.
David Boder: Hat sie noch Zeit gehabt ins Spital zu gehen?
Bernard Warsager: In...in...zwei (2) Wochen später hat sie geboren ein Kind, in Mädchen.
David Boder: War ihr Mann mit Ihnen...mit der Gruppe?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, der Mann durfte sie nicht sehen.
David Boder: Hm. Also weiter.
Bernard Warsager: Ich habe auch Dokumenten. Ich kann das zeigen.
David Boder: Und was ist dann passiert?
Bernard Warsager: Also wir haben, uns hat gelungen, wir haben durch einen Zufall...es war dort ein jüdischer Posten, durch den haben wir rausgeschickt ein paar Briefe. Und dann sind die Briefe gekommen zu den jüdischen Hilfsvereinen und Joint hat gewusst, dass wir sind im Gefängnis. Sie sind zu uns gekommen mit einem Wagen mit Essen. Aber die Engländer haben nicht rein gelassen das Essen.
David Boder: Warum?
Bernard Warsager: Warum? Die haben gar nicht gehabt kein Interess, wir sollen satt werden. Sie wollten, wir sollen immer hungrig bleiben.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Sie wollten wissen nur, wer hat uns die Möglichkeit gegeben, wer steht hinter unserer Organisation, die wollen nach Palästina fahren. Und ich habe viel Sachen nicht gesehen bei die Deutschen, was ich habe bei die Engländer gesehen.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Bernard Warsager: Die Behandlung.
David Boder: Seien Sie spezifisch, was war das?
Bernard Warsager: Wenn die sind durchgegangen, wir waren im Lager waren, haben wir müssen zu jedem Engländer die Mütze runter nehmen und auf Achtung stehen.
David Boder: Haben sie das befohlen?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl. Wir müssen...wir sind gezwungen gewesen zu dem.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Und der Deutsche war besser behandelt wie wir. In jedem Fall war er besser behandelt.
David Boder: Nun also, wo sind Sie von dort gegangen? Und wie hat man Sie raus gelassen?
Bernard Warsager: Das war Paderborn bei Staumühle. Die Ortschaft heißt Paderborn bei Staumühle.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Und...wenn wir sind raus gekommen, sind wir sehr schwach geworden. Und...
David Boder: Was haben sie gesagt, wenn sie haben Sie raus gelassen?
Bernard Warsager: Sie haben uns raus gelassen...der jüdische Wagen von Joint ist gekommen und die haben uns genommen.
David Boder: Aha.
Bernard Warsager: Sie haben gar nichts gesagt. Sie waren nicht so wie die Deutschen, sie wollen uns geben Dokumente, dass wir befreit. Das darf,...und die Öffentlichkeit darf das nie kommen, dass wir sind in einem Lager gewesen.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Und dann bei der Entlassung haben viele von unseren Freunden, von unseren Kameraden gefehlt Sachen. Uhren—Viele von den Kameraden haben gehabt sehr gute Uhren. Hat man sie ausgetauscht und viel haben auch gefehlt von den Uhren.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Und das ist auch nicht richtig!
David Boder: Also wohin sind Sie von dort gegangen?
Bernard Warsager: Von dort...von dort bin ich eben hierher gekommen.
David Boder: Mit der ganzen Gruppe oder alleine?
Bernard Warsager: Mit der ganzen Gruppe.
David Boder: Nun haben sie...hat man Sie reingelassen nach Italien?
Bernard Warsager: Herr Professor, Sie stellen mir hier eine Frage, ob man mich hat reingelassen. [kichert]. Ich werde Ihnen sagen. Während dem Verhör hat mich der englische Kapitän gefragt: ‚Na also, wie kommt ihr hier her so ohne Dokumente und so weiter?’ Ich sage: ‚Wir sind gezwungen zu gehen, ihr gebt uns keine Möglichkeiten, keine Dokumente. So stelle ich ihm die Frage, ich sage: ‚Was machen sie, wenn sie keine kriegen?’ Sagt er auch: ‚Wenn man gibt mir nicht, dann muss ich gehen auch.’ Ich sage: ‚Wir auch, wir sind auch gezwungen. Wir müssen gehen, es gibt keine Grenze für uns. Sein oder nicht sein, wir haben keine andere Möglichkeit gehabt. Und unser einziges Ziel ist nur Palästina.’
David Boder: Sie sind von Polen?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Nun die polnische Regierung sagt in der UNRRA und überall, dass man die Juden jetzt...dass man die Juden genau so behandelt wie die Anderen. Dass sie haben bestraft die Menschen von dem Kielce Programm und alles das. Was wissen Sie davon?
Bernard Warsager: Mit der Bestrafung geht es so. Es stimmt man hat bestraft, aber die Toten kommen nicht mehr zum Leben. Und wenn man wird noch hundert (100) Juden oder die restlichen Juden in Polen tot schlagen und wenn man bestraft die Anderen, die Toten werden nie wieder zum Leben...zum Leben kommen. Der Jude ist jetzt in Polen betrachtet als minderwertig und bei jeder Gelegenheit...
David Boder: Aber es sind doch keine Gesetze gegen die Juden in Polen.
Bernard Warsager: Ja, aber die Bevölkerung. Wenn Einer den Anderen ermordet, braucht er keine Gesetze zu haben. Das ist gegen Gesetz. Was helfen mir Gesetze, wenn man auf jedem Schritt...wenn man betrachtet auf der Strasse mich oder in der Wohnung, wann ich raus gehe am Abend. Und auf jeder Strasse kann mich ein Messer in den Rücken oder eine Kugel. Ist das ein Leben? Man kann nicht erzwingen, der Pole soll gesellschaftlich zusammen mit dem Juden leben.
David Boder: Nun also Sie sind nach Italien gekommen. Wohin sind Sie zuerst gekommen? Waren Sie in Rom?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, ich war in verschiedenen Städten. Ich habe mir auch die Mühe gegeben hier zu studieren. Ich bin dazu genommen worden auf dem dritten (3.) Jahr auf der Kunstakademie in Roma.
David Boder: Sie sind ein...Maler?
Bernard Warsager: Ja, ich bin ein Kunstmaler.
David Boder: Sie wurden dazu genommen.
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Und warum sind Sie dort nicht geblieben?
Bernard Warsager: Ich will nach Palästina kommen. Ich resignierte von meinem Studium weiter und ich will nach Palästina kommen. Das ist das Wichtigste. Ich stehe schon auf dieser Höhe als Maler, wo ich kann selbstständig alleine auch arbeiten und hoffe in der Zukunft die Chance haben, mich weiter mich zu lernen.
David Boder: Sind Sie verheiratet?
Bernard Warsager: Nein.
David Boder: Also was tun Sie jetzt hier? Erzählen Sie mir ein bisschen über die Hachsharah. Wie hat man das gegründet. Was heißt das Wort Hachsharah?
Bernard Warsager: Ich will erklären. Hachsharah vernimmt folgenden Inhalt. Wir lernen Arbeit zusammen. Wir lernen...wir lernen, lernen auch wie, wie man,...wie man pflanzt, wie man hacket.
David Boder: Nun Sie haben doch hier keine landwirtschaftliche Schule in diesem Platz.
Bernard Warsager: Herr Professor, wir sind hier nicht lange.
David Boder: Ja, aber das waren doch Andere bevor?
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Wie lange existiert dieser Platz?
Bernard Warsager: Der Platz existiert schon ein ganzes Jahr.
David Boder: Nun, wieso hat man nicht eingerichtet irgendwelchen Studien Möglichkeiten?
Bernard Warsager: Von hier kommen wir auf eine Stelle, wo Felder sind, wo wir praktische Arbeit noch mehr lernen können.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Bernard Warsager: Ich weiß nicht wie der Platz heißt . [flüstert]
David Boder: In Italien?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Aha. So wie lange denken Sie, werden Sie hier sein?
Bernard Warsager: Herr Professor, Sie stellen mir die Frage. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es Ihnen schon erklärt. Die Engländer lassen uns nicht rein. Und für uns gibt’s keine Grenzen, es gibt keine Gesetze, weil diese Gesetze betrachten wir als ungerechte Gesetze gegen uns.
David Boder: Hm.
Bernard Warsager: Und unser Ziel ist Palästina, Eretz—Israel.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir wer hält und wer verteilt die fünfzehn hundert ‚certificates’ jeden Monat? Wer kriegt es?
Bernard Warsager: Die Engländer rechnen ab von die Juden, die illegal nach Palästina gekommen haben.
David Boder: Nun? Also bleiben Wenige? Welche bekommt Ihr?
Bernard Warsager: Die bekommen die Leute welche haben sehr reiche Verwandte...
David Boder: Wo macht man die Applikation dafür?
Bernard Warsager: Das macht man in Palästina. Aber Sie müssen verstehen, dass so viele Leute sind geblieben ohne Heimat. Und die sind viel grösser wie hundert...wie tausend fünf hundert Zertifikate. Viel grösser als hundert tausend...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Ja, ich wollte nur die technischen Sachen wissen.
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Wer hat die Zertifikate in Palästina?
Bernard Warsager: Die Engländer geben sie den jüdischen Exekutiven, die verteilt das.
David Boder: Diese Exekutive ist in Palästina?
Bernard Warsager: Jawohl.
David Boder: Und dann...man schreibt dort oder sagt dort? Was ist es?
Bernard Warsager: Diese technische Ausführung hat mich nie interessiert.
David Boder: Sie wissen es nicht.
Bernard Warsager: Das ist mir unbekannt.
David Boder: Na ja. Also und, hm, so lange sind Sie hier einfach...Sie präparieren sich und Sie warten??
Bernard Warsager: Sie warten.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie hier...
Bernard Warsager: Herr Professor, im Moment...sollte ich sagen gar nichts...es gibt Dinge, die kann ich nicht so einfach sagen
David Boder: Ja. Also ich will nicht, dass Sie mir etwas sagen, was Sie nicht können. Ich wollte es einfach wissen. Aber Sie verstehen, eine logische Frage bringt eine andere logische Frage.
Bernard Warsager: Ja.
David Boder: Und es ist selbstverständlich, dass Sie nicht zu antworten brauchen, wenn Sie denken, dass Sie nicht sollen.
Bernard Warsager: Unsere Lage ist Folgende: dass wir haben nichts mehr zum Leben zu verlieren.
David Boder: Ja.
Bernard Warsager: Verstehen Sie; und der Mensch, der hat nichts mehr zu verlieren, kann nur gewinnen.
David Boder: Nun?
Bernard Warsager: Wir können nur das Leben verlieren. Dafür kämpfen wir. Wenn wir am Leben bleiben, wollten wir leben. Und wir wollen nicht mehr zwischen andere Völker, die uns hassen, allein bleiben, dann bleiben wir alleine zwischen sich. Wir wollen nur kein Mitleid von anderen...
David Boder: Nun ja, werden die Araber Sie nicht hassen?
Bernard Warsager: Wir sind eine grössere Zahl Juden. Wir können sich alleine alles schaffen, was wir brauchen. Wir hassen keine anderen Menschen, aber wir vertragen nicht mehr—kein Mitleid, keinen Hass. Wir wollen alleine für sich sein. Wir haben genug, tausende Jahre haben wir für andere Völker alles geopfert. Wir haben von uns gegeben große Männer . Was haben wir da? In jedem Land hat jeder Mensch geopfert das Beste, was er konnte und wollte sein der beste Bürger. Was hat man ihm dafür gegeben? Es gibt nicht kein Land, wo der Jude geopfert hat alles von sich, er soll sein hundert (100) prozentig anerkannt. Und er wird immer betrachtet als Jude. Das hat uns die Erfahrung von zwei tausend (2000) Jahren gelehrt. Und es gibt nicht keinen Fall in diese ganzen Jahre...von die großen Männer, die das jüdische Volk hat gegeben, er soll werden betrachtet auf dieser Höhe, wie andere Männer. Immer haben...
David Boder: Denke Sie nicht, es ist so, weil die Juden sich auch apart gehalten haben?
Bernard Warsager: Es waren verschiedene Versuche, dass Juden einen Weg gesucht haben durch Assimilation. Leider hat gezeigt der Weg, das ist nicht der richtige Weg. Und die letzten Geschehnisse in Europa haben das noch unterstrichen.
David Boder: Nun ist da noch etwas was Sie sagen wollten?
Bernard Warsager: Herr Professor, ich will Ihnen Eines sagen. Wir werden sich in der Zukunft alles erlauben, weil wir müssen endlich einmal in der Weltgeschichte anerkannt werden...
David Boder: Langsamer, ja?
Bernard Warsager: . . . als politisches Volk—unabhängig von Anderen. Dann erst wird man auf uns schauen als gesunde, normale Völker. Wenn nicht, dann wird uns jeder betrachten als minderwertig.
David Boder: Nun, Sie sagten doch selbst—jüdische Kraft haben wir nicht. Also wie kann man das durch setzen? Die Engländer verhaften alle, die jetzt illegal rein kommen wollen. Sie schicken sie weg wieder in Konzentrationslager. Also was will man tun?
Bernard Warsager: Also es ist so. Wenn die Engländer die selben Methoden, was die Deutschen haben gemacht, machen, dann können sie...dann können sie uns...dann können sie uns vernichten.
David Boder: Ja?
Bernard Warsager: Wir brauchen keinen Schutz mehr von die Engländer. Wir werden uns alleine beschützen. Wir werden in Frieden mit den Arabern leben. Und die Engländer wollten nicht das zulassen. Das passt nicht in ihre imper...imperialistische Geschäfte. Und dafür zerbrechen sie uns bei jedem Schritt. Und wie lange wir werden leben, werden wir weiter kämpfen. Leider sind wir etwas schwächer von die Engländer. Die Engländer haben ein Viertel ( ¼ ) von der...
David Boder: Hm...
Bernard Warsager: Aber Eines habe ich im Leben erlebt. Deutschland war auch gross.
David Boder: Ja? Und ?
Bernard Warsager: Und ist klein geworden. Und ich hoffe, dass England wir auch mal anders ausschauen, wie es heute ausschaut. Nicht durch Kraft und durch [unverständlich]. Die...die Geschichte zeigt, wieso England ist gross geworden durch Piraten auf dem Meer. Und jeder Mensch, wer hat sich interessiert an der Entwicklung, kann genau sehen, wie das alles ist gekommen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the report of Mr. Warsager, which started on Spool..., which started on Spool 104 and, hm, concluded on Spool 107. Tradate, a little town in Italy between Milano and Como. A place of a castle, which was, hm, first a castle, then a convent, then an Armory and finally has become a displaced people’s asylum maintained by the American Joint Distribution Committee and partly in cooperation with the UNRRA. An Illinois Institute of Technology Wire Recording.
David Boder: This section of Spool 9-107 is being separated and goes under the number 9-107A. It concludes the story of Mr. Warsager. Stop.